which costumes caused such an awful
experience that jennifer lawrence
literally ended up handing out
autographs to anyone who asked we're
checking out the intense and painful
processes the actors of the hunger games
had to go through when filming
how did lawrence end up losing some of
her hair
let's dive in behind the scenes
access this female part of my brain i
didn't even know i have i was like oh my
god
elizabeth banks looked great performing
on screen in the hunger games but the
costumes were often very painful to wear
it's very constricting and uncomfortable
and that's certainly how i feel
all of her outfits were custom-made for
the actress and banks even got to
contribute her own thoughts regarding
fabric shapes and colors in the
development process
unfortunately she didn't get to
contribute too much to the comfort level
and many of the costumes were torture
when the actress put on certain costumes
it literally changed her posture as she
found herself getting into character but
fashionista effie's way of standing is
far from comfortable for most people
banks can't even pick a favorite outfit
based on look because she's been left
with such painful memories so instead
her idea of a favorite was which one was
comfiest to wear this green puffy dress
oh my goodness
while jennifer lawrence didn't have to
feel the pain of actual poison fog she
did undergo the intense time-consuming
and uncomfortable process of having
multiple prosthetic boils attached all
over her neck and face
having this much prosthetic attached
with a special and not so comfortable
glue made the experience pretty tough
for lawrence
no water
the water helped at one point during the
production for mockingjay literally
thousands of pieces of prosthetics were
used it's an insane number but
considering they were for 250 people to
wear over the course of four days it
makes sense that means
250 performers also had to endure having
these elaborate pieces attached to their
body for filming
being a natural blonde jennifer lawrence
planned to protect her hair from
becoming damaged by harsh dye treatments
to go brunette approximately thirty
thousand dollars was spent to make weeks
for the actress to wear while filming i
rented thirty thousand dollars of hair
this would have been a great plan had
they followed through but in the end
lawrence was forced to dye her own hair
and went through all of the treatment
anyway
it worked out for a while but ultimately
intense damage was done to the actress's
natural hair so she was forced to chop
it off it got so bad that she went for a
full pixie cut because she felt she
couldn't get any uglier to make it all
worse the wigs did finally end up
needing to be used for mockingjay since
lawrence's hair was cut too short at the
time really we just kind of started
cutting away and then just kind of kept
just it just kind of ended up this way
it was stunning but the butterfly dress
that banks appears in was far from
practical it was a memorable experience
for sure partially because of the live
butterflies fluttering around her but
she pretty well wasn't allowed to do
anything except act in it the actress
couldn't eat walk or even really sit
to make it worse beneath the work of art
the actress was fitted into an awkward
and tight spandex bodysuit and i'm so
grateful that i fit into the sample
sizes because otherwise they were going
back in the trunks the famous fashion
designer iris van gerpen was responsible
for the wild shoes worn with the
butterfly dress
the avant-garde heels were extremely
impractical and were even hard to wear
just while sitting the designer shoes
were on loan to the production and
really did amplify the high fashion of
the character but it did make it
difficult for banks to do her job safely
they might be the feistiest pair of
shoes we've ever seen and we're not the
only ones who think so it's hard to
manufacture that when they do it so well
getting all of the extras ready for the
capital scenes was a massive feat not
only did the makeup have to be precise
a whopping 400 extras needed to be
tended to head of makeup v neal was
running a team of 30 makeup artists for
an insane nine and a half hours all
before being ready to film the capital
scenes with the extras ready to go we
are actually trying to implement a
eyebrow bleaching scenario for all of
them this process was intense and
exhausting for the actors who had to
wait the entire time sitting through
loads of makeup prep and eyebrow
bleaching the makeup artists had a rough
time as well on their feet for so long
doing grueling work efficiently and
professionally
see be prepared to have your eyebrows
bleached
what are we looking at a whopping 1800
different costumes were made for the
capital scenes for the first movie the
elaborate outfits weren't the easiest
for the actors to maneuver in they found
themselves limited by huge ruffles and
ties the reaping ceremony was another
intense costume day the performers were
super hot and suffered an extremely
unpleasant filming experience for long
hours on set the conditions were so
rough that even lawrence recognized it
wasn't good so she signed an autograph
for anyone who wanted one on set
you know things that you only really see
like in magazines that nobody would ever
really wear in real life the first time
tigress actress eugenie bondurant had
her extensive makeup done it took around
six hours to complete the whole process
by the time the team went to camera
bondurant still had to endure a long
three hours with three different makeup
artists working on her at the same time
the actress also had to sit through
getting tons of fake tattoos all over
her body all of which had to have
meticulous attention paid to them since
the look had to be consistent with the
tattoos needing to line up with the
facial makeup naturally
like a jigsaw puzzle the headpiece she
had to wear was also so frustrating it
made her delirious it's odd it's weird i
don't really want to do this all the
time jewel encrusted nails adorning
elizabeth banks's fingers made doing
pretty well any task like using a button
or typing on a blackberry a complete
nightmare the actress literally couldn't
even go to the bathroom simply with the
completely impractical additions banks
actually had people on set with her who
would accompany her to the washroom to
help her manage getting toilet paper and
unzipping her costumes
filming catching fire in hawaii was
difficult for a number of reasons and
the wetsuit jennifer lawrence had to
wear through much of filming didn't help
her one bit at one point the actress was
incredibly itchy and couldn't handle the
feeling anymore so she had to resort to
using rocks to help scratch the itch
what lawrence didn't know was that the
rock was actually a sacred stone and
dislodging it was a huge insult to the
community to make it all worse the giant
stone almost hit a man this wetsuit
reminds us of another very uncomfortable
costume when i would take it off i would
have just like red
marks all over my body for josh
hutcherson wearing a wetsuit was pretty
intimidating since a it was so
unbelievably form-fitting and b
the wetsuits were very hot to wear all
the time the actor would get extremely
warm working under the intense sun and
being super active on set which only
made the wetsuit harder to endure god
it's hot one of banks's most
uncomfortable costumes was this large
and structured red dress all the
material itself wound up being super
heavy leaving the actress to move around
carrying loads of excessive weight not
to mention the fact that she was also
wearing small heels making it even
harder for her to move freely let's go
show them becoming caesar flickerman in
the hunger games was no small task
stanley tucci actually contributed some
ideas as to how he thought the character
should look and it wasn't going to be
simple to achieve
chuchi tried multiple different
prosthetics and wigs before settling on
slicked hair with dyed eyebrows and tons
of heavy makeup the actor also had to
sit through a bit of dental work
a mold was used to take a cast of
tucci's actual teeth in order to create
false teeth for him to wear while
performing
this is what i want i want teeth that
maybe look like this actress jenna
malone had tons of prep to do before she
took on her role as joanna but on top of
it all she had to deal with some very
uncomfortable accessories and additions
when the actress was going through
makeup tests in pre-production seven
hours were spent trying to figure out
exactly what her look would be for the
different looks the actress donned
different huge and elaborate eyelashes
that had come from as far as germany and
japan
these delicate pieces were part of the
two and a half hour makeup process the
actress sat through for some looks
you guys look amazing creating the
hunger games films was by no means an
easy feat for anyone involved we don't
know who some of these experiences were
more painful for the actors going
through the process or the makeup and
prosthetic artists not to mention the
extremely long hours spent by the
costume team which actor experience
sounded most painful to you